stranger things has plenty of scares but
there are laughs too some of the
funniest moments were totally
unintentional which actors couldn't stop
laughing during takes keep watching for
the best stranger things bloopers
in the season 3 episode the case of the
missing lifeguard will played by noah
schnapp but decides to wake up his
friends mike and lucas in a rather
unusual way dressed in a purple wizard
outfit will press his play on his
cassette player which turned up to an
annoyingly high volume starts playing a
funny medieval flute song annoyed by his
circus act mike and lucas beg will to
stop the music and let them be and here
comes a part that didn't come out quite
right on the first try instead of saying
i have seen into the future and i have
seen that today is a new day a day free
of girls schnapp couldn't stop saying
another version of the line and i have
seen that today is a new day
a day
full of girls
yeah
in one episode from season two actor
caleb mcluckin who plays lucas sinclair
finds himself having to enter a
classroom with his back slamming against
the door walkie-talkie in hand once
inside he's faced with having to answer
to an angry elderly teacher for
disturbing her class as soon as
maclarklin turns around he's greeted by
an off-screen voice who asks if he hurt
himself
excuse me
[Music]
seems to be having the most fun during
filming and we all know that if you love
your job you'll never have to work a day
in your life
in a beloved bit from season 3 featuring
finn wolfhard as mike wheeler and millie
bobby brown as 11 an extremely awkward
and blinded by love mike tries to tell
the girl of his dreams how he truly
feels about her a scene takes place in a
supermarket where they're taking shelter
from the looming danger that awaits on
the outside and has the two characters
sitting on the floor face to face this
is the rehearsal we're rolling
hell yeah hi editors and what's editor
wouldn't be happy about seeing a
personalized greeting from finn wolfhard
himself while sifting through hours of
endless footage
being tasked with containing the other
worldly events that transpired in the
stranger things universe we can all
agree that dr sam owens is a man who
carries a tremendous burden on his
shoulders in a scene from season two's
will the wise at deadpool riser enters a
room wearing his glorious lab coat turns
to actor natalia dyer and charlie heaton
and is supposed to say it's not very
pleasant in here is it it's not very
pleasant in here it is
no wonder this became one of the show's
best blooper moments
after all the man is a natural born
comedian
the character of will buyers has
engraved himself in our hearts as a
soft-spoken well-mannered gentle boy who
would never hurt a soul well unless he
was possessed by the mind flayer in
season 2 episode the pollywog schnapp
and co-star finn wolfhard who plays mike
are staring down at dustin's trap
worried about the very angry creature
inside there's a frightened look in
their eyes
and in an attempt to express his shock
schnapp tries to gasp but instead this
is what came out
in season two's the mind flayer dustin
henderson played by gaytin matarazzo
finds himself having to run towards a
ringing phone in order to pick it up and
slam it back down on the receiver but in
one particular outtake he fails to do so
multiple times smashing the phone
against the wall while trying and
failing to hang it up
[Music]
when will buyers disappears and is
presumed dead hawkins middle school has
a moment to say a few brief words in his
memory a scene takes place in the
school's gym and has all of will's close
friends in attendance but their grief is
not shared by students troy walsh and
james dante as they disrespectfully monk
the boy who most people assumed has
passed away mike decides to confront the
boys for their behavior while the rest
of the school is leaving the gym and
pushes troy to the ground troy then
decides to attack mike but is stopped in
his tracks by 11 played by millie bobby
brown who uses her powers to make him
pee himself in front of everyone and
that's when another kid takes the
opportunity to make troy the butt of the
joke by saying dude troy peed himself
but that's not what we get in the
blooper kissing himself
struggling to keep ourselves together
while being terrorized by the thought
that she might never see her son again
joyce byers played by winona ryder often
finds herself entering into a mode of
hysteria in season two joyce and bob are
facing two government officials in
uniform the authority figures are in
full listening mode as the desperate
mother loses her ability to construct a
sentence which is more the result of
ryder totally flubbing her line and
grasping for the next word
in the season 2 episode the lost sister
11 sets out on a quest to find a group
of unruly outcasts including a strange
but powerful girl who's later unveiled
as carly prasad also known as eight
eleven meets up with becky ives to look
through some files hoping to learn more
information about other children the
hawkins lab has experimented on it's
here that 11 learns that kali was
kidnapped in england as a child it's
also here that millie bobby brown got
whacked over the head
in episode one of season three hawkins
chief of police jim hopper played by
david harbour sits eleven and mike down
in order to tell mike that something has
happened to his grandma in the actual
scene which is somehow disturbing and
funny in itself harper says your mom
called she needs you home right away
it's your grandma sounds simple enough
right nope far from it it's your grandma
[Music]
yeah
no
no i don't think so
[Music]
a few takes in harbor began defending
himself saying the word is so funny when
it comes to the most talked about
bloopers in stranger things history this
is the one that takes a proverbial cake
the official stranger things writer's
room twitter account dedicated a couple
of tweets to honor this special moment
with one of them reading legend has it
that david k harbour still can't say
grandma without laughing as it turns out
this is also one of the duffer brothers
favorite bloopers of the show
nothing there's nothing wrong with nana
what
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]